cold-open John you want to do a cold
open today so that must mean there's big
news the last time we did this I think
it was because I was announcing the
creation of Leon Maas on Twitter yeah
yeah his news in the history of our
projects together so I assume we only do
cold opens for big moments yeah yeah not
only was it the creation but also the
the announcement that he had a very
active Twitter profile which has
continued despite ya know despite my my
belief that it was not going to though I
still hold out that in a year's time
there will not be a lot of Leon Maas
happening in the world but who knows who
knows first off you're completely wrong
about that secondly I assume that we're
doing this cold open so that I can
announce the Snickers thing is that is
that what we're doing it for definitely
not no yeah I've been bigger news than
the Snickers thing which I guess we can
talk about later if you really want to
I'll hold off on the Snickers thing I am
definitely going to talk about it but
what what is this bigger news than the
Snickers thing well for today we are
announcing I am announcing for people
who are not extremely careful Watchers
of the Hanks Channel channel that
Katherine and I are going to have a baby
human child I'm so excited
a little a little person we're gonna be
parents and it's probably gonna happen
in late October which is why I am NOT
going to be at nerdcon stories as people
have been asking me Hank you're not on
the guest list of nerdcon stories WTF
that's what's going on this the fact
that you're not gonna be at nerdcon
stories is a very very small detail in
what is a very wonderful turn of events
I am so excited Hank and I have to tell
you our kids are so excited oh yeah
there is widespread widespread talk at
home about what the baby is going to be
like is it going to throw up is it going
to throw up white or green or yellow oh
great lots and lots of baby talk at our
house so I'm so happy for you and very
excited and that is worthy of the cold
open but I'm wondering if we couldn't
move on to my Snickers news before we do
that I just want to give a very brief
message from Catherine which
that while I chose this public weird
life she didn't and it's stressful
enough to be a pregnant person without
feeling it the whole world is watching
and thinking about you so she just
wanted me to put that out there so
people would behave with that in mind
and we are very happy for all the people
who are very happy for us though so
thank you thank you all very much
ya know everyone's excited for you but
it is it's it's an important thing to be
able to have privacy within your family
and to have a family life that's
separate from your public life I know
that's hard to ask when you have a
public life but but it is really
important so should we move on to the
intro yes hello and welcome to dear Hank
and John or is I free to think of it
Dear John and Hank it's a comedy podcast
where me and my brother John we answer
your questions give you devious advice
and bring you all the week's news from
both Mars and AFC Wimbledon so Mars how
you doing John I'm doing well
mostly hey do you remember in our last
episode how I mentioned that I dearly
want to have some kind of corporate
sponsor in my life huh-huh-huh well it
just so happens that this very week 478
Snickers bars arrived at my office the
nice folks at Mars mm-hmm the nice folks
at Mars sponsored VidCon and while I was
talking to them at a sponsor party I
mentioned that I am a longtime supporter
of their company via my affection for
Snickers bars
apparently this went up the chain
somehow and so a refrigerated box full
of delicious cool Snickers bars 478 of
them arrived at my office yesterday and
first off I just want to say thank you
to my personal sponsor
Snickers secondly I just want to say
other companies looking to sponsor me
please feel free to send me
478 of your products so so--but so what
you're saying is that you would just you
would just just having a chat at VidCon
first of all I have to say like we sell
all of the sponsorships out of my office
we have those relationships we have lots
of company Foca and never did it ever
cross my plate that an option for a part
of the VidCon sponsorship was just a
gigantic like house sized box of
Snickers that that didn't show up on any
of the any of the deals and I'm a little
frustrated that apparently all I had to
do was have a conversation with somebody
this is like the weird life of the
public youtuber where it's just people
are like hey yeah you like our thing
here have a have two years worth of of
them if I wouldn't say that 478 Snickers
bars is two years worth of Snickers
bytes I'd say it's closer to it's a
solid month though I mean I'm gonna have
a great I'm gonna have a great month of
August let's put it that way
I like Snickers very much but 478
Snickers bars is like 10 years worth of
Snickers mmm I'll report back next week
and tell you how it's going what else
the people that work no to the people at
the Mars company not the people of the
planet Mars I must say I really really
like peanut M&Ms a lot by the way I also
love peanut M&Ms for the record if the
people at bars are looking to have this
being stop stepping on my stepping on my
communications with the Mars people Hank
I'm wondering if there are other
products out there that you would like
to receive 478 of yeah if I could
receive like if I could receive 478
Hartford Whalers hats are you a fan of
the heart fruits like them because they
have a really nice logo and also they
don't exist anymore as it as a team
right so that does somewhat that makes
it that makes it a slightly less good
investment from the company's
perspective just because they no longer
have a brand to promote I
I completely disagree they have a
tremendous brand to promote it's
Hartford Whalers merge merge for a
sports team that doesn't exist anymore
is exactly what people like me who like
who like logos but not Sports is looking
for are looking for I myself I'm a
longtime fan of my Chevrolet Volt I've
had my bolt since 2012 and I would love
478 Chevrolet Volts if the if the
Niantic company could send me 478
pidgeys that would be fantastic because
that would really help me with the level
enough I mean if we're requesting 478
pokemons at a time Hank I can provide
you with 478 pidgeys they're sitting
there in my freaking list of Pokemon
right now what I need is 478 Jolteon
Zoar whatever before eons where where my
478 vaporeon Niantic I I feel like I'm
the greatest ambassador for your product
ever in fact tank while we've been
recording this podcast
I've been studiously catching retinas
which grow in Indianapolis like an
actual weed that that that doesn't that
doesn't sound great we you know I it's
every Pokemon is important though you
can't say that one is important just
that's important just because there are
lots of them that's not a very nice way
to feel just because they're successful
successful animals and our and our weird
weird you know human habitats pidgeys
Indra taught us and the drowsies they've
been very successful in the places where
we live and that's fine I think I think
we should reward them for their success
I'll tell you what else I'd enjoy Hank
478 pairs of the sweat pants that I wear
I just I'm sorry I'm stuck on how how
many Snickers bars are received and it's
given me hope that I'm really just a
request away from the 478 diet dr.
peppers that I desperately need to go on
living what about wait a second what
about if we could get a brand deal with
the US Mint and they could send us four
hundred and seventy eight hundred dollar
bills I mean I feel like that's a yeah
is that not an option they are they are
they open a brand-new today's podcast is
sponsored by the US Mint the US Mint
providing you with high quality
hundred-dollar bills since 1881 do you
know when the hundred dollar bill first
one in a circulation shop yes I think it
was 1881 everybody knows that I also not
that I want in any way to problematize
my relationship with the Mars company
maker of the greatest candies in the
history of the world but there are some
there are some other candy companies
that I wish would also sponsor me
okay the makers have fun dip if I could
have 478 fun dips that would make me
really I like fun dip because uh because
you put sugar on sugar and then you eat
a big league chew I would love 478
pouches of big league chew 470 at Abbas
Abbas please maybe 400 to be watching my
cots oh god I love a good
whatchamacallit who makes
whatchamacallit
why aren't they sponsoring us probably
Mars can I get can I get 478 uh but
pockys some pockys Hank whatchamacallit
sir made just a pocket watch Yuma what
Yuma cutlets are made by the Hershey
Company oh oh we need to reach out to
them if anybody listening happens to be
the CEO of the Hershey Company let me
just say that next to Snickers bars
whatchamacallit are my favorite candy
bars Hank we need to move on this is not
ultimately a podcast about us trying to
acquire 478 items it's ultimately a
podcast in which we answer our listeners
questions and provide them with
exceptionally dubious advice all right
John we have a question here it's from
Hank who asks dear Hank and John I'm
gonna be a dad soon and I'm terrified
help Hank broadly speaking I have three
pieces of advice the first is you know
to take care of the kid when they are
little infants that's most of what they
need is just care it's like quantity
time over quality time the second piece
of advice I believe I've given this
before on the
Podcast is to only read one parenting
book I don't actually think it matters
which one you read it but just to only
read one because if you accidentally
read two or three there will be all this
competing advice in your head while
you're trying to parent at three o'clock
in the morning and you'll be like am I
supposed to change this diaper and then
put them to bed or am I supposed to
change this diaper and then feed them
and then put them to bed just read the
one book so that you're not fighting
with yourself in your head at three
o'clock in the morning and the third
piece of advice I will give you when
when when my son was born I remember
calling mom and dad and saying I am
sorry because this whole time I thought
that parenting me was a joy minute by
minute in your life and that my presence
was a constant gift to you when in fact
like it parenting is a joy and the
presence of a child is a gift but it's
also lots and lots of work especially
when they're little because the the
amount of waste that they produce
diapers that they go through is just
astonishing and they don't know what
time it is and all that stuff so it's
it's a lot of work at first and they
don't give you much back because they
can't really respond to stimulus except
by crying but I'm so I'm still I'm so
I'm so excited for you so that's that's
my advice but the other the other piece
of advice I would give you is not to
listen to anyone's advice which is also
a great piece of advice in general on
this advice podcast especially on this
advice podcast I've got a question here
John that I feel like is tailored more
to your expertise than mine and since
we've already decided that this podcast
is gonna be the ones where one of the
ones where you talk more than me let's
just do it
it's from Tatiana who asks dear Hank and
John I'm currently studying to be a
nurse and therefore often encounter
people at the worst times of their lives
at these times and sometimes asked
whether I believe in God and as an
atheist these moments bring me a lot of
anxiety I completely understand that
they're looking for comfort and a time
of day
parishioner to lie to them I am simply
at a loss as to how to react in these
situations any dubious advice would be
greatly appreciated yeah I think this is
difficult but ultimately it might not be
a matter of lying it might be a matter
of stating your beliefs in a way that's
respectful you know like by saying that
you think care and love is important at
difficult times and that you've seen a
lot of people find that care and love
from religious places or turning it
around and asking them what they believe
or where they find strength or saying
that you like I also think you can just
say I'm not an expert on that stuff I'm
a nurse I am NOT a spiritual adviser
however here at the hospital we do have
wonderful chaplains and would you mind
if I called one for you or would you
like to talk to one of the chaplains
I think using the resources at the
hospital is or I assume that you're at a
hospital given that it sounds like
you're with people when they die but
most places that people die in do have
some kind of chaplaincy service so I
would encourage you to take advantage of
that because when I was a chaplain at
least I was always very grateful when I
was called in in those situations
excellent hit me with one John I have
nothing to add of course I have nothing
I yeah
it does seem a little bit like hey
that's I'm not qualified for that
question right I'm here - I'm here to
stick a needle in your arm I'm here to
take care of you I'm here to keep you
healthy I'm not here to guys you
spiritually yeah knowing what knowing
what your job isn't is as important as
knowing what your job is I think
absolutely all right we've got another
question this one comes from Rowan who
asks dear Hank and John I don't know
what to do when my friends keep forcing
me to get snapchat I don't really want
to get it mainly because I don't know
how to use it
nor will I use the app a lot any dubious
advice Ron you have no idea how much you
will use snapchat once you have it you
don't know and you might be right maybe
you won't use it but you
no like the so so first you have the
right to do whatever you want but this
is dubious advice for you which is that
not knowing how to do something is a
terrible reason not to do it because
then you would do nothing ever so
obviously using snapchat not necessarily
the most adventurous thing that that you
might say like I don't know how to do
that I'm not gonna do it
snapchat it's a little bit not on user
unfriendly it's a little bit a snapchat
it's a little bit user unfriendly but
you know the only way to know how to use
it is to use it and what I have
discovered about snapchat is that it is
a kind of it's a way to personalize
communication and I in a impersonal
world of communication I think often
times when we are texting with each
other it feels very functional it feels
sort of robotic and of course emojis can
help with that and I think that's why
I'm oh jeez are so popular and
successful but snapchat allows you to
create a thing for your friend and send
it to them and and kind of like make a
little present make this digital
presence that is going to you know exist
for a short amount of time but but it's
a little thing that you can send to them
and communicate that way and so your
friends just want to send you a little
present sometimes and they can't and
that frustrates them because they're
sending presents to everybody else that
they and in their little social world
and you not you when but again it's your
choice but if your choice but it isn't
really because Hank
feels very strongly that you need to get
snapchat because Hank is a ambassador
for snapchat peg is essentially an
unpaid employee of snapchat
can I get 473 snapchats please is 478
Snickers bars for the record those last
five Snickers bars when I eat them in
early September will be very important
to me I would add to this you may not
use snapchat a lot I for instance don't
use it at all really but you will enjoy
the filters
even if don't use snapchat the filters
are fun so I think get it for the
filters and no snapchat did not pay us
to say that but yes Snickers did send me
478 Snickers bars so when I say that
Snickers is delicious I am biased but I
am also correct
hashtag spawn we got another question
from Aaron who asks dear Hank and John
in one month I will be leaving home to
attend my first year of college in a
different state I'm just beginning the
process of packing up all my belongings
and clearing out my room during this
process I have unearthed some
interesting and many embarrassing
artifacts from my life so far among
these artifacts are old journals filled
with Harry Potter fanfiction I wrote
when I was in Middle School my question
is what should I do with these journals
filled with terrible fanfiction they are
extremely embarrassing in content and in
quality of writing and if I leave them
at home I run the risk of my parents
finding them and reading them but if I
take them to college with me I run the
risk of my roommate finding them and
reading them any dubious advice would be
appreciated oh my oh what it what a true
quandary John yeah you've got a
difficult one I mean you can't Aaron you
need it you need like a safe like out
like a fire safe that you only know the
combination to with wrapped in chains
and in zip ties that's the true only
secure method of storing anything it's
just lots of zip ties everybody knows
that if you want to preserve your middle
school writings the key is zip ties no I
think that you should leave it at home
because I think even if your parents do
find it and read it ultimately they
won't be like embarrassed they will
still be impressed because parents have
such a low in my experience anyway my
parents have such a low bar that I have
to jump over for them to be proud of me
Oh God so I think just the fact that you
use like periods and commas and capital
letters in appropriate places they'll
just be like this is the best fanfiction
I've ever read well you don't know how
embarrassing they are in content though
but but I do want to say to Aaron I
think it's remarkable that you you're so
certain your parents haven't read them
yet yeah that's the other thing right
just leave them at home where your
parents have already enjoyed I it's been
a long time since you wrote those things
who knows who knows what you what what
violations of privacy occurred I'll tell
you what though I think it I think it is
a dangerous dangerous game to bring
those with you to call it Karen yes very
I think I bet not I think that I think
that you're sort of I think if you bring
those to college ultimately you're sort
of playing the game of Thrones you're
either gonna win or you're gonna die
also how do you have space to take stuff
to college with you I remember taking
stuff to college I was like well if it
doesn't fit in this duffel bag I
remember when I got to college I had
three books with me and I put my three
books on the bookshelf and my roommate
looked over at me and he said you have
three books and I was like no no man I
have more than three books I just only
brought three books and he was like you
brought three books to college and I was
like yeah yeah then he proceeded to like
roll in you know like three bookshelves
full of great American novels and I was
like oh I've made a terrible
miscalculation what what you don't have
time to read for fun at college you just
got it yes you do you better because
that's the core of my audience I guess
that's true I guess that's true oh man
Hank let's go to another question this
one it comes from Christine who writes
Dear John and Hank question for you my
roommate believes expiration dates for
eggs and butter are a suggestion whereas
I was raised to follow expiration dates
is he right and if so how can I tell
when eggs and butter are expired really
great question now Hank as you know I am
a longtime supporter of expiration dates
but after supporting them a bunch of
people wrote in to say that expiration
dates are in many cases making the
problem of food worse because it creates
so much food waste so I was wrong
about expiration dates and now you are
going to continue by correcting me yes
in many cases they aren't even
expiration dates their sell-by dates so
the date at which the store shouldn't
sell them after not the date in which
you shouldn't use them after obviously
if you buy butter on like the last of
the sell by date you don't have to throw
it away the next day they expect that
you will have that butter for at least a
couple of weeks both eggs and butter are
two examples of things that are very
difficult to eat after they've spoiled
because they smell awful like if you
crack open a rotten egg
you're gonna know because it produces
like the oxidation that's happening
inside of there's going to produce a
bunch of hydrogen sulfide or the
bacteria of the faction of the bacteria
in there and hydrogen sulfide is the
thing that we are very good at being
able to smell because it's very toxic
and you know the smell of hydrogen
sulfide
it's that stinky rotten egg smell and
butter also has it's very similar to
like rotten milk like milk that has gone
bad it's sour and and yucky and but like
butter and both of these things are
things that last a very long time and
throwing them away because they have
past their sell-by date is definitely a
way to waste money and food okay related
question hank just out of curiosity
about how long after receiving a
Snickers bar in the mail can you eat it
I'm very curious I'm gonna google it
even assuming that I enjoy two Snickers
bars a day for the next mm you know 240
or dorso days I'm wondering do I need to
give some of these Snickers bars away or
can I keep them all I I think you could
just keep them oh my guess is but
they'll stop being as good they just
will be a little less fresh I had a
Snickers just the other day it was a
medon't I have no idea how old this was
I literally just found it sitting around
the office and it was one of my
individually wrapped little ones for
like Halloween times and I had like
three of them and two of them were like
you know normal and then one of them was
like half hard and I was like hmm this
is a little crunchy
your than usual but I ate it I ate it it
was just fine I think if I if we could
just back up real quick I am NOT okay
with you saying negative things about
Snickers in in any way even implying
that you had a less than perfect
Snickers experience in dangers my really
important relationship with the Snickers
company all right by the way it was
funny when you said I had a I had a
couple of those mini Snickers yesterday
because I should emphasize this is 478
full-sized Snickers bars and I had five
that's like that's like half your daily
calories and Snickers I know it was
actually all that I ate I'm gonna try to
see if you can lose weight only eating
Snickers bars ah that sounds like a real
good plan John well they have most of
the things that you need protein
carbohydrates vitamin C I assume does
Snickers have vitamin C ask the internet
two milligrams point point two
milligrams that's all you need you don't
want to have more than 0.2 milligrams a
day it's well I mean first off I'm
getting way more than 0.2 milligrams
because I'm meeting several of them a
day you also get point two grams of
trans-fat and I my understanding is that
the trans fat is the stuff that's really
good for you oh yeah that's the superest
that's the super good you should rub it
all over your skin and eyeballs
okay let's I we're veering dangerously
close toward its seeming like I am not
incredibly grateful for these 478
Snickers bars so I want to emphasize
that I am profoundly grateful and that I
think I I will say and I'm not saying
this because of influence from the
Snickers company that I think it's a
little bit ludicrous when people eat
these nutrition bars these quote unquote
nutrition bars that have the exact same
yeah nutritional qualities as a Snickers
bar and then they're like oh but it was
a Clif Bar and I'm like right but that's
the exact same thing just again it's
like I often run it across granola bars
and I'm like that's actually
cookie that's a cookie that's but it's a
bunch of chocolate chips it's delicious
it's great I I don't have any problem
with a granola bar but don't try to
pretend that it's healthier than a
cookie it's the same thing as a cookie
it's just a cookie it's a cookie it's a
cookie that you're supposed to eat while
you're outside for whatever reason this
is an outside cookie this is a hiking
cookie it's a cookie for hikers lembas
bread anyway John I made the Lord of the
Rings look what are the Rings reference
now I feel like a nerd I gotta ask you a
question it's from John who asks dear
Hank and John is what allowed to refer
to their superiors in a workplace as a
co-worker or to their inferiors in a
workplace as a co-worker
does this create a power imbalance or a
power equality that is undesirable to
parties involved thank you for all your
work the first thing that I would say is
that you are definitely not allowed to
refer to your inferiors as your inferior
that's not okay
I think that people do sometimes call
those people subordinate so also that's
terrorist awful that's terrible man
subordinate to me no I think you're
allowed to call yes you're allowed to
call them coworkers in my opinion at
least I mean we have a somewhat weird
office but I call everybody here
coworkers and I assume they call me a
co-worker but I think you can also refer
to people who are your bosses as your
bosses but I don't think that you can
refer to them as superiors or inferior
x' at least not here because it just
creates it creates a hierarchy that I
don't think is helpful to the running of
the organization like we aren't the army
yeah I think that the so so different
workplaces are different and the safe
bet is to go if you're talking about
somebody who's at the same level of as
you at your company the safe bet is that
those people are your coworkers and then
if there are other people you can call
them colleagues and that is safe but I
think there are some people who would
feel it in like big corporate structures
who would feel sort of weird about
calling someone who was you know their
boss's boss a co-worker but you could
still call that person
that person works at your company and
you work together on the same project
but if you work at Amazon
can you call Jeff Bezos your colleague
not really I mean you know you can't
call him your coworker I'm saying that
our advice is so dubious that I already
disagree with it yeah yeah so what do
you call that person I think you have to
call Jeff Bezos Jeff just calm Jeff yeah
I think you just have to be like you
know I was at I was at dinner with some
of my co-workers and Jeff was also there
yeah well yes yeah I think you you kind
of can't and it's very weird to me I was
just at comic-con and there was a lot of
like single naming happening when we
when referring to particularly famous
people and I was I was like Patrick who
and and people would just be like you
know Patrick Patrick was there Patrick
who was Patrick Rothfuss who Oh
Patrick Rothfuss is is a great man I'm
not sure that he's quite gotten to a
place where he's the only Patrick yeah
yeah uh-huh uh-huh though I did I was in
an elevator with Joss with Joss is the
only Joss well I'm first of all his name
is Joss which is pretty weird
secondly he's the only Joss I mean if I
say I was in an elevator with Joss then
that I was indeed you know I would
however I when I do not know someone I
always work very hard to say their first
and last name in conversation because I
think if you don't you sound like a jerk
like frankly if you were like I was in
an elevator with Joss it makes you sound
like you're his friend
yeah and I find that kind of problematic
right because clearly not though do you
want to hear the whole story
not really but I can tell that you're
gonna tell it regardless so I was
leaving a party that that Joss had Joss
my friend Joss had been at and and and I
heard that he had been at the party but
I didn't see him and I was like ah
bummer and then I was walking back to my
hotel because I had had an
of that noise it's not more pleasant
place that ever been
and and me and my friend Laura or we're
walking down this causeway that was sort
of limited in size and there was this
group of people that were walking quite
slowly that had clearly come just come
out of the party and Laura Laura and I
were walking much more quickly because
it was bedtime and and she like sort of
like had to push past them to get us
through and as we got a far enough away
that they couldn't hear I had to tell
Laura that she had just kind of shoved
Jospeh and she was like what and I was
like that happened it happened you
touched him and a little bit pushed him
out of the way he was the sweaty one and
she turned around and looked and she was
like yep yep yep yep yep that's what
happened and then I went on to get into
the elevator to my hotel and and they
they caught up while I was waiting for
the elevator and we got in the elevator
together and they and one of the people
that were hanging out they she
recognized me and was like eh you hang
green and I got to be Hank green in
front of Joss Whedon which was made me
feel special but not to Joss Whedon it
wasn't like Joss Whedon looked at you
and said are you Hank green no he sure
did not know in fact I I did not say
anything cuz I was terrified and so I
didn't say anything at all so I feel
like Joss might have not known that I
knew who he was at all which probably is
not a thing that matters to me now that
I think of them no no it does not matter
to him and also as is always the case
with any kind of celebrity interaction
you have way over analysed as a
situation
yes definitely okay let's move onto
another question from one of our
listeners thank this one comes from God
this one comes from Kathy who asks dear
John and Hank my 21st birthday is coming
up on August the 2nd and everyone is
telling me that it is incredibly
important that I get drunk they say
everyone should be drunk at least once
and that you really should do it on your
21st birthday because it is a rite of
passage etc but my question to you guys
is do you really think it's that
important I don't really want to get
drunk I hate the idea of being drunk and
not being in control of myself or in a
situation and also alcohol tastes bad
first off caffeine alcohol does not
taste maybe well I mean maybe you don't
like the taste of solar ethanol taste
maybe pure ethanol taste but maybe you
don't like the taste of some alcoholic
beverages but don't throw the baby out
with the bathwater okay there are some
delicious alcoholic beverages out there
have you ever had a really top quality
margarita I'm eventually going to get to
the fact that you don't need to get
drunk on your 21st birthday but I just I
just want to disagree with your premise
a little bit first or a really really
good old-fashioned a well-balanced
old-fashioned with really top quality
bourbon there is nothing wrong with the
taste of alcohol that said you don't
have to get drunk on your 21st birthday
what a ridiculous idea yeah I gotta say
an old-fashioned is not for me but have
you tried a Zima mmm it's good
good give one of those mics hard
lemonade's or like I strawberry wine
cooler like some Boone's Farm yeah oh
yeah these might be the three most
embarrassing things that you've ever
said in your entire life Hank the last
five minutes of this podcast has been
some of the lowest quality Hank I've
ever received in my entire life I just
John I just want 438 x'mas first off I'm
trying to get if the corporate sponsor
here you need to memorize the number of
Snickers bars that I got how many is it
what's at 4:38 458 oh god it's hard to
remember all that second off if anybody
sends Hank 458 x'mas I will be so happy
because Hank may say that he likes Zima
he might remember something from the 90s
when he enjoyed ah Zima but he does not
want to drink 458 x'mas no one on earth
wants to drink 458 Dimas by the way I'm
not even sure they still make Zima Hank
so nobody probably even gets this joke
if I got 458 zimas it would definitely
be because somebody went back and
or or somebody's just sitting on a
stockpile from from 2007 because I think
that's oh wow yeah production ceased in
October of 2008 so going back to our
question of when food spoils I'm not
sure that you really want to enjoy 458
eight-year-old Xena's take me like
several years to finish all of them I
will say as someone who is currently not
drinking but but I have enjoyed drinking
I do like I would do like to get a
little bit tipsy on occasion that again
just like you're just like our previous
snapchat friend you don't know whether
you'll enjoy something until you try it
of course that's not necessarily a
reason to do it like I mean you can say
the same thing about crack cocaine right
right like and I'm I like I'm not like
people are like you gotta try Scott I
think it's so fun and I'm like no no
never that is not who I am and if it's
not who you are that's like that's fine
but it is a it would I would suggest of
course doing whatever you want to do but
if you want to try drinking just have a
glass of white wine and see how you feel
about it don't like put a bunch of
pressure on it it's just it's just like
it's a thing that some people do and
enjoy and you might as well try it and I
also think like I I find the American
obsession with binge drinking really
weird and scary and I think that it's
great if you can go out on your 21st
birthday and have a glass of red wine or
even split a bottle of red wine with a
friend or something or white wine or
Rose a was the best of both worlds I
just have to say that that as if Cathy
doesn't like the like to think that she
likes the taste of alcohol like white
wine is like not a lot going on which I
really like it's cold it's like it's
just it's basically sprite if you get
like I'd really sweet Riesling and that
then it's like a very approachable first
step whereas red wine it always seems to
me like ah there's a whole lot going on
here heck is trying so hard to get Cathy
to drink
her birthday I mean this peer pressure
is way worse than the peer pressure that
she's getting from her friends anyway
I'm saying he's gotta find a Zima get
yourself a Zima and you'll be you'll be
so happy that you did great on your 21st
birthday I I would say like I think it's
fine to go out on your 21st birthday and
celebrate the fact that you can drink
legally but being responsible about that
is the reason ostensibly that you're
allowed to drink legally right so I
think like the coolest thing you can do
is in my opinion is either not drink or
go out and have a couple glasses of wine
with your friends and enjoy it and go
home that night and not wake up the next
morning vomiting or whatever like yeah
it is a a health problem to drink to the
point of extreme intoxication it is a
risk to your health it is a danger to
your health and I want to underscore
that yeah I did not want to be part of
the romanticization of binge drinking in
American culture and it could be a very
overwhelming thing especially if you've
never done it before to think that
that's what drinking is because that's
what we write anta sighs and that's what
we think of as like the 21st birthday
celebration when in fact that is not
what drinking should ever be yeah but I
mean it's it is very closely associated
alcohol consumption and binge drinking
in the u.s. are so closely associated
Hank we need to answer one more question
before we get to the news from Mars and
AFC Wimbledon John I feel like I feel
like you're criticizing me for having
said the wrong number of Snickers bars
but I feel like you have said different
numbers
yeah I've probably also been
inconsistent all I know is that there
are between 438 and 478 Snickers bars
currently in my home and that yesterday
95 you're at home you brought them home
just for you yeah of course I brought
them home you think I'm gonna share them
with all the people who work here oh
those are my Snickers bars Hank I feel
like if you have that many sneakers
to be clear was not addressed to
everyone who works at Jon's office the
letter was addressed to me okay all
right Sarah and the children are also
not welcome to have any of them
those are my Snickers bars all right
John maybe one more question this one's
from Eddie who asks dear Hank and John I
recently went through some old flock
brothers videos I stumbled across a
video from January 2009 with the title
President Barack Obama inaugurated some
historical background in this video John
offers quote maybe someday I will tell
you the story of how the Declaration of
Independence almost didn't happen
because a dude got drunk in a bar I know
this is maybe 7 years too late but I
really want to hear that story hate me
too John yeah so about that story it
turns out to be something of a
historical legend that is not true so
the reason I never thought the story is
because in the comments of that video a
bunch of people were like I can't
believe John bought in to that legend it
totally isn't true here are some
reputable sources so I'm backing away I
backed away 7 years ago and I'm just
gonna keep backing away
which reminds me Hank that today's
podcast is brought to you by quietly
backing away from your seven year old
mistakes quietly backing away from your
seven year old mistakes the only real
strategy today's podcast is also brought
to you by the use of the word jokes as
if it means cool a thing that we thought
that we were creating when in fact
already existed and so we also backed
quietly away from that back in 2008 and
furthermore this podcast is brought to
you by babies babies babies yes yes oh
god oh god
and finally this podcast of course is
brought to you by Zima bottle cold fresh
malt liquor available in 2008 oh man the
poor folks at Snickers didn't even get a
sponsor spot I think they should be
happy I think I think they got enough I
hope we've done a good enough job
talking about how much we enjoy
receiving 400 odd copies of something
for us to get 400 odd copies of
something else in the mail sometime soon
in the meantime Hank it is time for us
to discuss the week's news from Mars and
AFC Wimbledon would you like to go first
sure right away no short poem today just
oh yeah what can you do right moves on
we were too busy talking about the
all-important Snickers news yeah yeah
and all of our 400s what Evers well if I
could have 400 of anything John it would
be Mars curiosity Rover's yes that's
what that's what Mars needs it needs
more minivans so so there is currently
on the surface of Mars that
extraordinary piece of technology the
Curiosity rover among other things that
the rover can do it can shoot Martian
rocks with laser beams vaporizing the
surface of those rocks and then it can
detect and sniff up the chemicals that
come off of the rocks and do some
spectroscopy on it to figure out what's
in the rocks and the chemical
composition of Martian geology and it's
great so every once in a while we beam
new software to the Curiosity rover it's
basically like you're updating your xbox
new firmware new hard new software not
new hardware to be really nice if we
could beam new hardware to it but we can
and and and we just sent a software
update to the Curiosity rover that
allows it now instead of needing to wait
for humans to tell it when to shoot its
laser and where to shoot shoot its laser
which of course takes a ton of time
because we are really far away from Mars
and it takes you know like 15 to 30
minutes for our signal to get there so
instead of waiting for all that time the
Curiosity rover now has an algorithm
that allows it to decide for itself
where it should shoot its laser beam and
what rocks to take measurements of which
is it's gonna save time and it's gonna
allow us to do more
science faster on the red planet and
that's exciting how and the good news is
for people who are concerned about
robots that can choose for themselves
where to shoot their laser guns that
this one is very far away and and humans
are not anywhere near by it
so you're saying yeah I mean that was
gonna be my first question my second
question however is let me give you a
hypothetical situation okay imagine if
you will that we create software that
essentially allows machines to have a
consciousness sure and now imagine that
we are able to update the Mars rover so
that it gets a software update
essentially giving it self-awareness and
giving it consciousness okay okay in
that situation would you attempt to
argue that there is a person on Mars I
mean not until this moment
absolutely and all right well that it's
already John it's already making
autonomous decisions I don't know that
we can't say that there isn't already
currently a person on Mars well see I I
had a feeling that you were gonna get
there eventually so I just want to say
right now that the the bet that we made
is whether or not there will be a human
being as fine as a member of Homo
sapiens on Mars before 2020 annexes a
person I do not think that we said
person so I'm just I want to establish
that a machines are not people yet and
be the is whether a homo sapiens will be
on Mars by 2028 and I am NOT putting at
risk what I think of as the most
important issue in my life right now
which is whether we are only 12 short
years away
from having a podcast called Dear John
and Hank in AFC Wimbledon news so as you
know Hank right now it's the preseason
AFC Wimbledon is getting ready for their
third tier campaign right now literally
right now as we're recording this
podcast they are playing in a pre-season
friendly match Crystal Palace their
longtime South London rivals Crystal
Palace currently play in the Premier
League AFC Wimbledon play two leagues
below in Ligue 1 so it's definitely a
game where you would expect Crystal
Palace to win
it's a preseason game so there's tons of
substitutions they don't always play
their best players etc however Crystal
Palace scored early in the first half
Connor Wickham really great player
scored that goal and you know it was
looking like the natural thing was going
to happen AFC Wimbledon was going to
lose to a much stronger squad but then
the Messi for Montserrat the Christiano
Ronaldo of the Caribbean Lisle Taylor
Lyle Taylor scored a goal in the 38th
minute to make the game tied at one and
the second half just started so it's 1-1
very encouraging preseason news for AFC
Wimbledon and and I'm gonna keep my
fingers crossed that we can go in to the
start of this season feeling good
feeling excited and feeling like we can
stay up in Ligue 1 so I feel like yeah
sorry John why are you yawning I just
didn't have enough oxygen in my brain
okay feel like I didn't get a lot of
updates on you know like AFC women's
didn't like rebuilding its team in the
in the and the team in the time before
yeah I mean I wouldn't say that AFC
Wimbledon has signed a ton of new
players yet next week I will be giving
you an update on the overall kind of lay
of the land with the squad but frankly
we should be fine we have Lyle Taylor he
does nothing but score and that should
be enough we'll see I'm a little worried
as well about the fact that we haven't
signed that conovan players at League
One level but maybe the
or the group is good enough for lead one
we shall see all right all right I have
no idea how soccer works frankly neither
do I but I love it
I also have no idea how Mars works but I
like that as well I will remind you
though Hank that this week as as is the
case every week Leon Maas over at
Twitter twitter.com slash Leon must for
Earth is doing the hard work to make
sure that humans do not go to Mars until
at least 2020 well he now has 9000 77
followers John including many many
people I know personally as friends so
well you may not know to think but Leon
Maas has actually become the world's
leading anti Mars exploration advocate
ah well there is no one on Twitter with
more followers whose job is primarily
centered around making sure that humans
stay on earth until at least 20 28 I do
I I really feel like creating like a
Swindon Town Twitter like like Swindon
must beat AFC Wimbledon like that's the
only thing this Twitter is about you
know Leon musses newest newest tactic
Hank I don't know if you're familiar
with this but Leon Maas has become
strongly Pro moon exploration Leon Moss
is like wait what happened to the moon
let's bring back some moon exploration
why all this emphasis on Mars so far
away so cold so distant the moon very
habitable it's well it's close by
there's no doubt about that
what do we learn today John well Hank
the most important thing by far is that
we learned you're going to be a father
yes does doesn't seem like all the other
things that we learned might might be a
little bit less less impactful by
comparison I'm not really sure how to
follow that one up ya know I mean that's
definitely the biggest news of course
the second biggest news is we learned
that in the coming weeks or possibly
months but I suspect weeks I'm gonna be
eating a lot of Snickers bars now you
have a whole Snickers baby and we
learned that Jeff Bezos if you work at
Amazon it's not your colleague
he's just Jeff yes Jeff and lastly we
learned that Hank really really really
wants you to get snapchat his career now
to advising you to drink Zima while
using snapchat filters that's actually
sound like a pretty good time no it
doesn't that sounds like a terrible time
not least because the Zima is going to
make you sick on account of it being at
least eight years old possibly more
thank you for listening to our podcast
you can send us questions at Hank and
John at gmail.com also you can now send
us questions at dear Hank and John at
gmail.com thank you to Sammy who with
her friends from our forum your pants
started the dear Hank and John tumblr
dear Hank and John tumblr com
they have very generously given us
access to dear Hank and John at
gmail.com so we can now see your
questions there as well but as a lots of
people have been sending questions to
dear Hank and John a gmail.com
but that either the dress is Hank and
John a gmail account the email address
one one more time is Hank and John at
gmail.com that is the place to email
don't ya
yep that's the place the our podcast is
edited by Nicholas Jenkins
rosianna halse rojas helps out with
questions our intern is Claudia Morales
the music the cheering right now is from
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget the ability
[Music]